there's some sets I don't like going to
you Tami Roman had nothing but laughs
while filming her new comedy fall girls
there's a wild night
there's a dead box mm-hmm and then
there's all these funny women I never
had a chance to play this type of role
yeah and without giving away too much of
my character which is why you don't see
a lot of me in the trailers is because I
am the twist to the entire movie what's
a bit big take away with Linda okay this
is what I'm gonna give you Linda plays
the boss's partner okay and so when
these young ladies think that they've
killed their boss Linda had an ulterior
motive and actually making that come to
fruition is the comedy it's a little
weekend at Bernie's what a little girls
trip you know a little mixed in I just
want to thank the ladies for an amazing
season but I think it's time for me to
go straight on when you made to part
ways with Basketball Wives LA you know I
I actually loved doing basketball what
I'm just at a place right now where it's
about protecting my energy and my space
and my Zen I have to protect it I have
to protect it and so even within the
basketball wives world it's like if I
were to go back certain changes you know
would have to be made for me to be
comfortable in that environment but
we're still in talks and so I don't
necessarily know if I'll return but we
are talking about how everybody can be
comfortable in that environment and I
know from the reunion it was really hard
to watch have you been in contact with
Evelyn and I typically don't speak about
Evelyn in any of my interviews so this
I'm doing this for you you know we just
we didn't speak before you know taping
we typically don't speak after and I
think both of us just owe ourselves a
greater service of not allowing me not
coming into her space and her not coming
into mine just respecting bounds
I respect that I respect to women being
able to have that conversation on your
own timing and it doesn't need to have
cameras it's only to have care it
doesn't even need to happen I just feel
like you know yeah we know what it is
and we both can move on accordingly the
last thing I want to talk about
something you handled really well where
the break-up room was with you and
Reggie have you guys talked about never
getting married at all is that the final
thing with that you know Reggie and I as
he sits in the corner because the world
needs to know that my answer is gonna be
based on the fact that he's sittin in
the corner you know we've talked about
it we've kicked it around we're really
good we're in a good place and I don't
think that we need to put any pressure
on ourselves about having that piece of
paper and when the moment presents
itself we'll jump out there and do it
[Music]